if you ask me name one core reason
suicide rates are up we didn't pay the
price in 2009 I'm just a believer in
checks and balances and because we have
massive entitlement and over coddling
predicated on not having the proper
adversity based on our actions like
literally before every video before
every single video now that I'm gonna
put out I mean that may not be yet we're
still playing what were you thinking it
was gonna be more my voice yeah I still
don't know what the deal really
I do like Vaynerchuk using Victor I have
15 Facebook 15 YouTube just cuz I really
think it on by the way honestly I know
I've been [ __ ] but you know I need a
youtube 201 class hook me up because I'm
dying all about the pre-roll yeah where
it's contextual but even pre-roll and
jet like I need to get educated to
bumper ads the six-second unskipable
it's troub you as pre-roll but if the
whole six that can play if we add six
seconds or tells you yes like a five
dollar CPM you watch the whole thing
it's great for just like frequency
messaging just like yo a [ __ ]
Budweiser can in your face it's not what
we want for via Facebook for the longer
form what-have-you no I get it but you
can just Oh Caleb get your [ __ ] together
hit up the team what do they need from
me
let's go what do you need I'm not
confused I know this ad is upside down
but everybody's upside down and
Happiness and making money swipe up and
get on it right side up all right the
next one is the meeting with Dustin
clear all that was the one where you
told him to DM five [ __ ] on Instagram
and tell them if he wants to work for
this Dassin yes this this skateboarder
thing yeah is this a pre-roll this is
video
hey guys worried about to watch is a
impromptu sit-down Caleb big shadow TV
for grabbing the camera and capturing
this with Dustin on my team we were just
doing a meet and greet he's been on my
team for a little bit just want to get
them known better and we got to go and
we got going for so many of you
youngsters this is a video that is going
to change the outcome of your life watch
this podcast pay attention to this this
is a sit-down I have with Dustin on my
team all right I got to do this real
quick
cool and just getting people to
understand that this is not throwaway
content this isn't test and learn right
like if you know for example a UFC
fighter that grew up in Montreal when
you run creative 23 pieces of content
over a four-week period in Montreal
running media ads against Montreal like
you know it's cold it's going to work
but as you know not even us nobody's
producing that level of content to
fulfill the needs of the media
capabilities that we have in a Facebook
and Instagram and Google world this is
what the industry will look like in
seven years and a lot more than it does
today may not look at exactly this and
that but we will absolutely go down in
history in the ad world of like setting
the tone because the way the internet
actually works this is a requirement
everybody has to reframe the way Amazon
reframe the way Walmart how to do
business the way Netflix reframed how
ABC and NBC how to do business we you
know everybody talks about change in
this and at the forefront but like then
when it comes
people struggle within I've empathy for
that
[Music]
not judging yourself you've been talking
about this a lot recently and for
whatever reason I don't judge other
people and it starts with myself and
it's a very powerful thing of course I
judge people like but I don't judge that
I guess that you know you know of course
let me rephrase things run through my
minds opinions but judgment like is like
its final it's absolute and I just think
everything's gonna work in progress or
moments in time or angles or contexts or
you need to know so much more I just
have no interest in being so wrong I
care too much about myself to judge
other people like you don't know me and
that means I don't know you and so you
know everything is within context
everybody's so absolute you know world
is gray I don't but I don't give a damn
about you one bit
funny on the table turn around - check
it for me I know
- can't believe I made it with the music
I know think about me your buddy think
you're drowning in me solo if the
comment was in town I appreciate it
where am I going this way
[Music]
I appreciate I'm so stoked thank you my
god I see in December
[Music]
do you need me to get Mike do anything
for me I get ready and if you need
make-up to get you with a car I'm good
I'll take whatever whatever it is and so
I'm done with this when I'm done with
that I'm done there we're done okay
awesome
thank you we have to do one make sure
you got it I know what to do oh you got
it my god I got the longer I'm literally
every single entrepreneur I know has
somebody filming them
d-roc some [ __ ] now he's like like
much herb people you're like hi I'm
Craig I'm a d-roc I know cuz I'll be in
the zone again we're sitting here
editing the vlog and this next section
is gonna be really heady but I think it
shows kind of how Gary talks about how
he will listen really well if it's a
subject that he doesn't know so you
don't hear him talking a lot but I think
this is really interesting particle
physics
the principles of causality and locality
which allowed dr. Hart socket to
discover the Higgs boson and he
translated it
and now when we looked at artificial
intelligence we wanted to see how can we
adapt the process that deviates from the
realm of sensory and motor output but
rather has the conscious aspect of these
consciousness is a force that allows us
to adapt it allows us to take the
sensory input and our predictions from
the past and test whether that
prediction was successful given the
audit you were provided if it was
successful we reconsolidated as a memory
of the neocortex
we dismantle it we built something that
is context that is contextual
consciousness is what AI is
fundamentally missing 100% adaptability
not be hardwired and we can only
understand that
[Music]
it's such an interesting collaboration
[Music]
like how does it like in your point of
view what is it one of the chess moves
in the evolution of this like once we
for me when we mapped our DNA like even
you know like how did had operations
happen 300 years ago I think I think
back to context Cubans are unbelievably
bad at understanding things in 50 or 100
year windows like when I hear you go
through that obviously a lot of things
go over my head because it's not what I
understand what I know for facts facts
is we know dick [ __ ] about the brain and
the brains the [ __ ] game it's game
and so and so for me I you know I know I
think about you know it's funny the word
privilege is very much in the culture
today I genuinely actually getting
goosebumps to me mental privilege trumps
everything you know to me that's what's
up my guy so Joe my mom it's right it's
so real like when people like what do I
mean my ultimate privilege
my ultimate privilege is not up that I'm
a white male or that I had a good pic
good parents my ultimate privilege is
that it's real quiet and calm and
delicious and my [ __ ] dome yeah and I
and I think that when people look at
privilege they see the exterior is so
whether it's this or that whatever may
be whatever it may be but it's so
misleading to actually what this game is
about and so when I hear that go way up
here for me intellectually in the
details at its most macro once this
thing gets wrapped
you can get into a very interesting
place growing in there such a pleasure
so close yeah man pleasure
[Music]
I believe the reason that most people
that actually had the steak weren't you
know aka the skill don't get discovered
is because they don't know how to get
discovered you know the reality is going
to LA and being discovered is a very
1987 point of view in a world where
producing the content here in a YouTube
or Instagram or Facebook world is a far
more likely way to be discovered and so
I think it comes down to perseverance of
distribution
[Music]
in your opinion what needs to happen for
mass adoption happen with crypto just a
matter of time you know in 1996 I
thought by the year 2000 everybody would
buy all their wine on the internet it's
just it's a shocking lack of patience if
you're thoughtful about blockchain and
currencies you'll actually understand
that it's not in Russia America or
China's interest for this to play out
and I think people are naive in thinking
that those three entities are going to
give this thing up so easily right and
so my bigger thing is if you really
understand blockchain [ __ ] Bitcoin for a
minute yeah or crypto even currency if
you actually understand the foundational
aspects of a decentralized world you're
gonna have to convince me why China
America and Russia are gonna sign off on
that right so I think that the macro
political climate is a tremendous
indicator of why crypto and blockchain
are have a big fight ahead of them
welcome seven presidents
thank you I'm in my village
[Music]
I appreciate that gratitude is a
powerful thing you're preaching you
become real vulnerable real fast thank
you so much thanks for having me so I've
been spending the last couple of hours
meeting a bunch of people here and it
really allowed me to kind of frame up
where I wanted to go with my talk and
and I think the word that's most
populated to my mind right from the
beginning you always the right but
lately you've been into the purchase and
as I've heard you say before a lot of
these cats are into tactics and that
quick stop so if you were to rate those
two things tactics immediate strategy
versus the poor stuff I'm a big believer
in both I could have great mental thesis
that doing push-ups is gonna help me but
if I don't do them you know look if I if
I had to choose it I always think that
strategy and mindset is gonna be the
trump card because that is basically
dictating a lot of your actions the
problem is so many people stop there
what's happening is they're insecure and
they just want to keep feeding the brain
they don't want to do because they're
worried about judgment
they both [ __ ] matter right you got a
you know this is the reason so many I'm
unbelievably socially liberal but the
vulnerability is its ideological you sit
in a [ __ ] ivory tower and you don't
do right it's easy to tweet me - are you
doing anything about it so it's really
important they both matter and exit a
hundred percent you know like a I think
about life like a bridge you've got to
be pulling a lot of people like getting
me into a contradiction I'm like exactly
you got to be pulling from opposite
directions right clouds and dirt like
you got a you got a have for Bato and
gills I mean but what this you know the
reason so many people like me is because
I'm never gonna lose touch to that place
[Music]
I'll explain I think the biggest thing
you have to do is just an employee you
have to deploy Beach it's it's not gonna
happen overnight
right that's what I learned from you no
I [ __ ] put out hunter four and a half
years before you better get if I have to
dream you have the dream but you have to
execute it I'm just gonna take you time
because either at 15 you're gonna make
it up and try to front which is your
vulnerability or you'll just put in the
work put in the work put in the work and
that's it like it's just a process man
like this is the hump like you know like
put out the word
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] is the absolute
vulnerability I kind of I kind of like
love everything about your voice and
what you say so stream over ranch so
like it kept me in my seat like I'll
just telling up like bro like you're so
down freakin earth thank you thank you
my god
thank you for saying what you have to
say like never keep mixing your words
and stuff like it's an inspiration to me
thank you so much to me up front
thank you so much bro thank you for the
love that's very sweet patient she's a
nice medium and patience bro patience I
would literally give up everything I
would literally give up everything I
have to be 15 years old I literally give
up everything I have just understand
what the [ __ ] that means
don't be any holier you know you wanna
get to bother Molly up all the Sunport
[Music]
my entire belief that so much of our
shortcomings in society is that we
didn't pay the piper in 2009 the the Mac
if you ask me if you ask me
name one core reason suicide rates are
up we didn't pay the price in 2009 I'm
just a believer in checks and balances
and because we we have massive
entitlement and over coddling predicated
on not having the proper adversity based
on our actions parents today want to
blame social media and other things of
that nature what parents aren't
understanding is we are going through
the greatest era of mass over coddling
of children and try right now if you're
a modern parent and this is obviously
generalizations but the current modern
parenting is so over predicated on
taking adversity out of the child in the
first 10 years we're creating zoo
animals if you eliminate all adversity
in the first five seven nine years from
your children when they start facing
adversity at 12 13 15 because you can't
over cuttle everything they're just not
complete they're completely and utterly
not prepared for it and so you want to
give your kid an eighth-place trophy
because you want him or her to feel good
about themselves that's fine the problem
is that map's zero to real life when you
thought you're a winner your whole life
because you always got a trophy even
though you [ __ ] suck you're not
you're not doing any any good and I
think that if parents actually were
worried about getting jobs in 2010 11 12
13 14 and 15 and putting food on the
table
they wouldn't have worried about little
Ricky and kindergarten getting picked on
and went to the principal's office 13
days in a row and and I really genuinely
believe it and I know that that is a
pretty macro like I'm not unaware that
that's a pretty lofty thesis I I just
know my truth I believe it I don't know
what else to say
right yet yeah and it's 10:57 so I
should leave thank you guys
okay and if you guys need anybody to
like talk to somebody next year and like
cosign and say it was a good event I
would be happy together thank you so
much I mean that by the way it's statue
limitations over but I think I bought
liquor from your store when I was
underage I love that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]